Thanks okay boomer okay boomer okay okay
boomer any time a meme so profoundly
captures the collective imagination
we're a wisecrack have the impulse to
take out our detectives wipe and figure
out why the phrase articulates a
prevailing sentiment amongst the youth
the boomer generation ruined the world
and should kindly stop writing op-eds
about how Millennials are killing the
Olive Garden the latest social media
retort is employed by Millennials and
Gen Z errs in response to condescending
insults political grandstanding and any
other out-of-touch comment made by older
folks the term has become one of the
year's most salient memes and earned a
couple of industrious kids highly
profitable lines of merch so while the
intergenerational animosity a society
finally breaking down our young people
just a bunch of Aegeus jerks to
understand how we found ourselves in an
okay boomer world we first need to look
at the origins of intergenerational
feuding and why boomers in particular
are so right for online takedowns let's
figure it out in this week's wisecrack
edition on okay boomer why hating
boomers is so hip intergenerational
hating is a tale as old as reproduction
young people have always resented old
people ancient roman poet and satirist
juvenile called the old all alike and a
disgusting sight while Geoffrey
Chaucer's famous 14th century canterbury
tales accuses old men of boasting
fibbing anger and greed conversely
adults have always been skeptical
cynical and downright disgusted by kids
these days in 1695 author Robert Russell
bemoaned children as they have played
about the streets have been heard to
curse and swear and call one another
nicknames while in 1790 Reverend iNOS
Hitchcock complained that romances
novels and plays had poisoned the mind
and corrupted the morals of many a
promising youth in 1927 a clergyman
hilariously told Atlanta college
students that modern girls were Hellcats
with muddy minds another enemy in that
same decade was jazz music with one
doctor writing in the New York Times
that the blossoming art form was making
young people become absolutely bad and
some criminal of course in this case
railing against the young often came
with a dose of racism still whether the
enemy is nicknames novels jazz Hellcats
or tick-tock the
Altaf always thought the youngins to be
a lost cause clearly throwing
intergenerational shade is as an aid to
the human condition as unexpected
flatulence an election however the way
okay boomer took off makes us think that
there's something particularly salient
about the current generational divide
ironically I'll look back across the
decades suggest that the one
generational constant has been hating on
baby boomers to figure out what inspired
the first wave of boomer hating we need
to go back in time real quick to the
medieval ages youth culture a brief
history profound generation gaps are a
relatively recent invention as [ __ ]
youth hasn't always been a protected
time for frisbees trick-or-treating or
Saturday morning cartoons for most of
history children were essentially seen
as small adults and worked like them in
medieval Europe the average kid aged
seven to nine was sent away for seven
long years to take an apprenticeship or
become a servant for a different family
regardless of social class this
continued until the end of the 18th
century when people became more
concerned with children's personalities
in large part thanks to philosopher John
Locke who wrote the children were
innocent blank slates worthy of
protection this caught on and fortunate
upper and middle class kids were slowly
freed from work allowing them to play
with dumb wooden toys and be educated in
a fledgling school system still for most
kids work was primary and social life
was largely confined to the family and
these kids went to school at all
they spent summer vacation working with
their parents on the farm rather than
learning how to make out at expensive
sleepaway camp after the Industrial
Revolution not wealthy kids became
valuable resources and factories and
what is either called child labor or
take your child to work day every day
then in the mid 19th century our
understanding of childhood began to
shift further increasingly people saw
adolescence as a period of precarious
immoral development and industrialized
nation states started making government
provided education mandatory while
collective religious schooling became
increasingly popular around the late
19th century youth became increasingly
idealized as the Western world's first
modern wave of obsession with health and
vitality blossoms
young people who seemed to exemplify
those qualities became the new ideal by
the 1900s
advertisers began relying on
upper-middle-class youngsters to model
their fashionable wares and advertise
their expensive sporting goods by the
late 1920s a cult of youth was firmly
established in Hollywood and the popular
press which celebrated young adulthood
as the most privileged period of life
according to scholar Heather Addison at
the same time
childhood and adolescence became
increasingly protected in 1904
psychologist G Stanley Hall famously
wrote about adolescence and encouraged
segregating children by age and creating
collective institutions for educating
and socializing them by 1920 school was
required for children aged 8 to 14 and
as young people went from being seen as
workers to being seen as students the
first bricks of a budding youth culture
were laid historians typically marked
the 1920s as the first emergence of a
detectable generation gap by this time
the number of kids going to college
began to skyrocket and an absence of
parental supervision youth culture was
born on ivy-covered campuses in the form
of dating best friendships social clubs
and rampant consumption of films novels
magazines music and more as a result
middle class urban young people began to
model themselves more on Hollywood stars
and famous athletes rather than Grammy
and Grampy Bob in their hair dancing the
Charleston and generally having a grand
old time unsurprisingly the youth
culture they built became an obsession
with the wider culture at large
equally glamorized and reviled by their
elders when high schoolers swelled in
ranks following the Great Depression
influence became centralized in the 18
to 14 demographic notably demonstrated
by the arrival of the magazine 17 the
word teenager became a marketing
buzzword and mass popular culture became
increasingly centered around people
without wrinkles meanwhile arguably the
most consequential war of modern times
was being fought and won by the Allies a
baby boomer is born the war ends and the
post-war baby-making commences like lots
and lots of babies 76 million in fact
but the time the oldest post-war baby
was heading to college the baby boomer
generation constituted about 40 percent
of the American population rendering
them an undeniable force on the American
economy and culture bore
in unrivaled swell of post-war wealth
baby boomers pretty universally had
better lives than their parents
typically members of the greatest
generation who lived through the Great
Depression and fought in World War two
by contrast baby boomers largely grew up
in middle class plenty may be fairly
their lives were viewed by older
generations as easy and idyllic full of
Leave It to Beaver antics and largely
absent things like starvation and polio
they were also raised with comparatively
permissive parenting thanks in large
part to the writings of one dr. Spock
who encouraged parents to view the world
from their kids perspective as we've
seen wherever you find wealth coddling
of children and leisure time you're
bound to find some brand of youth
culture and indeed the 1950s witnessed
the true rise of this culture as we know
it today the toy industry exploded
supplying boomers with all the train
sets and baby dolls their heart's desire
comic book sales hit the roof while
children's television flourished absent
the parental advisory concerns kids
today experienced the teenager
technically invented in the 1940s really
came into its own as a distinct
sociological class with the baby boomers
a lifestyle which came complete with
rock and roll soda pop diners and
increasingly affordable consumer
automobiles you could use to stupidly
race your friends their childhood also
coincided with fast perpetual evolution
and education health civil justice and
technology as well as near constant
increases in prosperity the generous GI
Bill put former soldier dads to work and
the educational grants associated
allowed their parents to achieve wealth
some of which the Boomers would then
inherit America invested heartily in
itself from improving infrastructure to
starting NASA as Bruce Gibney venture
capitalist and author of the harsh
founding a generation of sociopaths
notes the sheer breadth of this era of
innovation is literally still benefiting
us today
he writes that your iPhone is charged by
power distributed over a mid-century
grid and depends on government-sponsored
research on GPS the internet and the
integrated circuit all dating back to
investments made in the 1950s boomers in
general attended massively reformed
public school systems less wealthy
boomers saw their family incomes
supplemented by social programs while
Medicare promised boomers grandparents
and parents the prospect of a
comfortable
tire 'but massive taxes the highest
margin being literally 92% in 1952
allowed the boomers parents to pay off
our wartime debt promising them a bright
and prosperous future boomers rebel but
then the generation that had it all
suddenly had something unexpected to say
they didn't buy into their parents
hard-won dream of middle-class comfort
and unfettered patriotism enter their
rebellions of the 1960s which saw the
growth of the civil rights movement the
feminist movement and the anti-war
movement see well every generation
somewhat embodies their parents worst
fears boomers were a veritable nightmare
for their elders while seemingly
ungrateful to boot where their parents
willingly banded together to be Nazi
Germany boomers defiantly burn their
Vietnam draft cards and commandeered
university buildings in rage-fueled
uprisings where their parents dutifully
form nuclear families boomers
scandalously explored premarital sex
drugs and rock and roll needless to say
this shocked their straight-edged elders
and the first wave of boomer loathing
was born this time
boomers were attacked for being too
radical for rejecting Authority for
being supposedly destructive and
nihilistic older people increasingly
took refuge and more conservative
political spheres as characters like
Ronald Reagan rose to power by
contrasting their own morals to those of
the protesting college students at
Berkeley Columbia or Kent State where
several college students were gunned
down by the Ohio National Guard while
protesting the sentiment of boomer
hating traditionalist was summed up by
country musician Merle Haggard a member
of the Silent Generation in his song
okie from Muskogee which became an anti
boomer anthem we don't smoke marijuana
in Muskogee we don't take our trips on
LSD we don't burn our draft cards down
on Main Street we like living right and
being free essentially kids in the 1960s
raised hell and frequently did so with
the social cause in mind and to their
parents their defiance was frequently
interpreted as the behavior of
ungrateful hooligans it's more
complicated though while the boomers are
often celebrated for all the social
changes that came with the 60s there's
one small caveat Harvard professor Lou
Inman and argues that we should
the boomers too much credit pointing out
that basically every major activist
figure was actually a member of the
Silent Generation and a few were even
members of the greatest generation he
cites everyone from Malcolm X to Gloria
Steinem to the de facto leader of the
Berkeley Free Speech Movement Mario
Savio to psychedelic drug advocate
Timothy Leary noting that all were born
before 1946 further he calls into
question the Boomers impact on culture
pointing out that just about every
prominent writer and artist of the 60s
was decidedly older than boomers
including writers like Allen Ginsberg
James Baldwin and Ken Kesey
as well as musicians like Bob Dylan
Janis Joplin and Jimi Hendrix the list
goes on
Menander argues that the boomers less
revolutionized culture and more absorbed
a revolutionary culture built by their
elders while the older Baby Boomers did
participate in anti-war protests some
were still in kindergarten when the bulk
of it went down so there's that the Me
Generation
even if the Boomers were all about
flower power the 70s are typically
located as a turning point in which they
evolved from dreamers into something
else fittingly their roots for their
recent wave of baby boomer hating was
also born as they were accused of being
self-absorbed narcissist somewhat
ironically boomers would eventually love
that exact same criticism at their own
millennial children they were accused of
creating a me decade by journalist Tom
Wolfe and historian Christopher lash who
chronicled the 1970s rise of the self
and personal development Wolfe wrote
that the new alchemical dream is
changing one's personality remaking
remodeling elevating and polishing one's
very self and observing studying and
doting on it in his book getting loose
lifestyle consumption in the 1970s
scholar Sam Binkley notes that this
decade marked the emergence of a
consumption oriented lifestyle ethic
centered on lived experience and the
immediacy of daily lifestyle choices
whereas the 60s youth movements were
preoccupied with mobilizing the masses
adult boomers in the 70s were more
interested in books on health and
virtuality and all natural food Binkley
credits much of the shift to the
increased mainstreaming of
counterculture books and texts
which advocated everything from cycling
to gardening to massage to recycling all
in search of a more authentic self but
an increased focus on the self almost
inevitably necessitates a decreased
focus on society according to Binkley
the 1970s consequently inspired a
culture of narcissism and formed a new
morality of self-realization through
consumption leisure experiential
learning and therapeutic release
particularly among white middle-class
folks the commercial potential of this
new lifestyle was not lost on marketers
and we saw the emergence of our modern
lifestyle markets in the form of
exercise fads diet fads and self-help
vets as boomers made more money and grew
up they slowly became the establishment
against which they had raged by the
early eighties boomers constituted the
grand majority of the American
electorate
according to give me by 1993 they
controlled the presidency and much of
the house by the mid 2000s that control
increased to 79 percent what's the
legacy of their economic reign over the
US well it depends who you ask
according to give me boomers inherited a
rich dynamic country and have gradually
bankrupted it the way he sees it
boomers raised in a time of
uncompromised prosperity simply assumed
things would always be that easy that
the economy would grow wages rise and
the generation below them would grow up
to have a better quality of life a fact
which is for the first time in recent
American history no longer true the
younger generations now hate them
ironically the flower children of the
1960s slowly became hated for everything
they had reviled middle class conformity
and mass consumerism in 1990 Time
magazine wrote about the rise of
Generation X even then the
intergenerational hatred seemed palpable
with Gen Xers being defined in part by
their dislike of Hall things boomer they
hate yuppies hippies and druggies they
sneer at Range Rovers Rolexes and red
suspenders
then came the Millennials who the media
had a blast pitting directly against
their parents Millennials were derided
by many a boomer penned editorial for
being selfish lazy entitled whiney and a
host of other unkind adjectives since
many Millennials came of age during the
Great Recession
they were left the most vulnerable their
financial lot has remained the leak
Millennials now make 20% less than
boomers did at their age
despite being better educated as if dad
insult to injury baby boomers are
comparatively flourishing with their
annual spending power of seven point one
trillion estimated to hit thirteen point
five trillion by 2032 in this climate is
it any wonder that articles about
Millennials clapping back at their
elders provide reliable entertainment in
this context boomer hating starts to
make sense
their parents resented them for me loud
flower children and now their children
resent them for mean buttoned up
self-absorbed corporate sellouts who
only stress about whether they're local
Chili's will close the sad and funny
thing is this it even seems like some
baby boomers hate themselves and recent
commencement speeches grown-up post-war
babies like New York Times columnist Tom
Friedman and Apple CEO Tim Cook
apologized for their generations legacy
as boomers increasingly reflect on the
world their children stand poised to
inherit a world created largely by them
one has to wonder just how okay they
feel but what do you guys as hating on
boomers more than just a fun internet
fad is the anti boomer sentiment
justified let us know what you think in
the comments as always a big thanks to
all our awesome patrons who support our
podcast and channel hit that subscribe
button and as always peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]